when um he was a celebrity and you know
on TV he used to come on Fox he was
great he always raided he was fun to
talk to he I he invited me to a couple
these Celebrity Apprentice things which
I went to he was always very gregarious
you know he walk in he'd give you the
big hug and kiss and like it was tough
not to like Trump and then he decided to
run for president and he invited me to
go down to Mara Lago you've got to see
it it's so beautiful sent me all these
pictures of it I was like hell no why
I'm not going to Mara Lago the guy is
running for president guess what a lot
of other journalists did not make the
same Choice then he found out that I was
going on a girls trip and we were going
to stay at Trump I know one of his
hotels and um he tried to pay for
it let me ask you something else that I
think it just popped in my head as you
were saying something this is probably
more what I would ask ask you offline
but we're on camera why not do you when
you have all these relationships with
these people the politicians and then
the other pundits and the talking heads
and all of that do you find at times it
can be tough because I this is just
personally what I found now is that
because I'm F friendly at least with so
many of these people and know them and
have played basketball with them or had
them over for dinner whatever sometimes
there's this piece in me where I want to
not criticize someone as much as I
should or I at least have to think about
it in a different way or you don't want
to say something about a certain
politician because then they won't do
your show like how do you balance all of
that because you've been on both sides
of this mainstream and now this side
you've interviewed everybody you
basically know everybody I've never
heard anyone say a bad word about you
except maybe some people at NBC so like
you know like how do you balance all of
that and still um maintain
Integrity I have very few friends you're
on a very short list my friend realiz
that's nice you didn't realize how
valuable this this friendship was to me
no I have a very short list I I don't
fraternize with them if they're
politicians I don't Frane with them you
know it's I'll give you one example I'll
give you two examples um V ramaswami
first came into my life as somebody who
knew Jed rubenfeld of Yale law school
who's a brilliant professor and they'd
been co-writing pieces for the Wall
Street Journal uh editorial page or
opets and uh on legal issues and I was
like oh these are good legal issues they
were getting at sort of the erosion of
free speech and I know Jed a bit he's
married to Amy Chua tiger mom anyway
yeah yeah I've had so I knew them a
little and so I got to know V and I
started he WR books I started reading
his books and he'd asked me for comment
what I know him a bit like him fine I
would fraternize with v then he decided
to run for office it's done it's off
we're not friends sorry we're
adversarial that's the only way I can do
my job honestly um you it's fine I I'm
not like your enemy now yeah but it I'm
going to hit you I'm going to hit you
repeatedly if you do dumb things or
things I I I think are dumb or worthy of
challenge not to say I'm the ultimate
Arbiter but I am of my show and um it
can't be that friendly anymore it just
can't be so you kind of know he's
running for office this is not the end
of our personal friendship but it's
definitely going to be on pause for a
long time and then my second example is
um Donald Trump when um he was a
celebrity and you know on TV he used to
come on Fox he was great he always raid
he was fun to talk to he I he invited me
to a couple these Celebrity Apprentice
things which I went to he was always
very gregarious you know he walk in he'd
give you the big hug and kiss and
like it was tough not to like Trump and
then he decided to run for president and
he invited me to go down to maralago
you've got to see it it's so beautiful
sent me all these pictures of it I was
like hell no I am not going to Mara Lago
the guy is running for president guess
what a lot of other journalists did not
make the same Choice then he he found
out that I was going on a girls trip and
we were going to stay at Trump I know
one of his hotels and um he tried to pay
for it he he reached out to say where
are you staying I'll take care of it oh
very nice right quotes it's not nice and
I said absolutely not thank you very
much Mr Trump we'll pay for our own
hotel and I said to Abby my assistant
make sure you hold on to the records you
know like they this is what politicians
try to do and humans try to do it too
it's one thing for Donald Trump
celebrity to try to woo me over to
liking him that's less fraught but
politician Donald Trump has to receive a
hard no in response to all those
overtures and Dave that night I went on
to the debate stage August 6 2015 and
asked him that very hard question there
were lots of hard questions just that
one that everybody remembers you know
what I had behind my notes in addition
to my outline and my fact checks which
are 10 Deep and I was ready to back up
everything I asked I had the receipts
from that Trump Hotel visit and my
rejection of his invitation to go to
maral Lago because I didn't want anybody
using that against me same as I'll have
to do it to V ramaswami if he ever tries
to say you did you know like it's just
it gets very complicated when you have
to cover them objectively so I think you
know you either have to choose or you
have to just be very open about your
bias you know like I know you're a
disantis guy you've been open about that
so I think you're okay there but if you
have too many of those with with
politicians it can get dicey quickly
yeah and for sure you know for just from
for my perspective like the politician
version I don't have that much of it you
know I played basketball with Ted Cruz
or I played video games with him we're
like some of that stuff but we're not
like friends like that I think for me
it's more like the pundit class where I
see guys that that are like kind of
doing what we do and then they kind of
go completely off the deep end and I'm
like do I have to call you out it's more
that I think for me than yes well you
have and the answer is yes you do have
no I do and like you I have my my short
friend list so you can I've got to tell
you one other
um so couple years back there's this guy
his name is Carlos Watson he invites me
to go on his YouTube show never heard of
Carlos Watson like who is he Abby's like
I don't know but your sandwich in
between it was like LeBron James and
Bill Gates so I'm like who is this guy
like he's got access to some very big
names um and I don't remember what the
Forum was on but it was on a big was
like election night and uh so I'm like
okay I'll do it she's like he's got all
these followers the show is very
successful okay so I I did it Carlos was
a perfect gentleman very nice guy solid
interviewer had a good time then I went
on a couple more times fine eventually
I'm like you know what I launched my
show I'm like I'll have them on had him
on very nice kind of kg about like what
his background was he didn't want to
talk about his life but that's fine some
people are like that then he wanted me
to go to his Azie Fest it's like a you
know like one of those media things like
Jordan has you know everybody goes okay
I'm like I don't know then I see the
list of everybody who's going it's like
all these amazing names people I respect
people I
know I'm like all right you know I'll
look into it then the next thing I
see Carlos and Azie media are under SEC
investigation for impersonating a
Youtube CEO the the officer the chief
executive or COO of the company as
Goldman Sachs was trying to figure out
whether it was going to give Azie
another business loan and wanted to kick
the tires and see if those YouTube
numbers were real well instead of
connecting them with the actual YouTube
his CFO faked being the YouTube
executive lied about their numbers the
whole thing Came Crashing Down it was a
house of cards that was all made up the
YouTube numbers were fake Carlos pretty
soon thereafter was under arrest the CFO
was under arrest Aussie Fest was off and
I'm thinking to myself it don't become
chummy with any of these people and I
went out on the air and I'm like I've
got something to tell you members of my
audience this guy who we had on not too
long ago and celebrated his independent
entrepreneurship he's a fraud according
to the government and several others
anyway it's just the whole business is
fraud and if you become friends with me
there's a 90% chance you're going to
wind up being a fraudster because that's
happened to me over and over Dave Rubin
if you're looking for more uncensored
opinions from today's thought leaders
check out our media playlist and if you
want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future vide be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell